hello everybody I am sitting here with
father Andrew Dominik father Dominic is
an Orthodox priest he's also an author
he's written a few books and he is a
podcaster he's been doing several
podcasts but mostly recently he started
an interesting podcast on the
relationship between Christianity in
general orthodoxy in particular and Toki
ins work in the Lord of the Rings in
this mullerian and and his other works
and so I thought it would be a really
interesting opportunity to talk to her
father and you just because I know a lot
of you who are watching you're
interested in stories like mythology
like traditional stories and a lot of
you are also fans of Toki so father
Andrew maybe you could introduce
yourself a little bit tell us about your
journey I know you are a convert to
Orthodoxy as well you know your journey
into orthodoxy but also to Toki an end
to these types of stories
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro
welcome to the symbolic world
well thank you very much well first
thing I'll say to introduce myself is
that my last name is pronounced d'emic
damningly I will try to be careful with
that yeah it's it's it's not a really
common name actually and in fact is a
sort of Americanization of a Lithuanian
name which is Jamaica which I kind of
wish sometimes that my great-grandfather
had just sort of left it alone but here
we are but yeah for me actually the the
journey into orthodoxy and junior token
are kind of bound up together and the
reason for that is that having read
Tolkien from when I was quite young I
would say I don't know maybe starting 8
or 9 years old you know that very much
shaped my imagination and shaped my my
worldview in terms of what was not just
sort of possible but kind of what I
expected from the world and I think then
when I encountered the Orthodox Church
in my early 20s so I've been Orthodox
now for about 21 years when I
encountered the Orthodox Church my early
20s in some sense it was like an
experience of we it's all real like like
like this kind of world where the the
transcendent is just at the threshold of
the immanent that's actually a thing you
know so so I was very receptive to
orthodoxy I think as a result of that
and not that my Evangelical Protestant
upbringing regarded the world as as flat
but it kind of sequestered the
miraculous and the supernatural into the
Bible and into some time in the future
and largely speaking although it did
kind of allow for the possibility of
miracles yeah but it wasn't like it was
like we were walking up to the threshold
every time I went to church on something
that's not what we what we did yeah
whereas as an Orthodox Christian I would
say that's that's what I do you know
that is my normal daily life so you know
my my vocation is as a parish priest
a pastor of a church in eastern
Pennsylvania and I'm also a husband and
a father have four kids and I've been
podcasting with ancient faith radio for
about a decade now and this new podcast
that you mentioned is actually my fourth
podcast and I've also got a few books
with ancient faith publishing and some
blogs and I just sort of seem to
accumulate content much as you yourself
to so that's kind of me in a nutshell
well I think I think it's very
interesting one of the I have noticed
and I've noticed that you know with with
Nicholas Kotar but also with just
priests in general when I meet Orthodox
priests I they have this kind of they do
have this kind of strange token culture
especially converted priests it seems
and a lot of Orthodox converts and I
think the way that you phrased it to say
you know that wait a minute you know
this is real I can actually live in a
story that has this magical quality to
it I think that you really hit the nail
on the head in the sense that you know
the the liturgical life and this idea
even even the fact that priests even
their vestments you know when you see a
priest there's something about it that
is that is accepting of a grander
reality of something which is is more
and you know when you you read these you
read the token and you read this idea of
an ancient world which is almost also
being lost you could say and there's
this it kind of it kind of peeks in you
know and all of a sudden you you get a
sense that you're connected to this
ancient thing and I think that that's
also something that is there should be
there at least in Christianity once you
start when you read you know that the
early church fathers for example I when
I read st. gregory of nyssa it was as if
exactly as if i was plunged into this
magical world and i thought you know i
can live in this story i can i can to my
life can be plunged into this this story
the same story that moses was part of
you know and i think that that's a it's
an amazing thing that we have access to
yeah i and you know i know some some
orthodox converts their sense of this
can sometimes get a little miss directed
towards pining for
the glories of some particular past
Orthodox culture or something like that
but but the truth is really that this if
we should have any kind of nostalgia it
should be nostalgia for paradise right
in which the the the veil between the
transcendent and the imminent is
basically not there you know that Adam
and Eve walk with God in the garden you
know and and so I I I've seen that in
and and but I think what you're saying
is true that there's this the sense of
connecting with something ancient
something powerful something where you
know the divine the the mystical is just
kind of on the edge of our actual
experience and I think a lot of that is
based on what we what we expect actually
of our story
like do I expect that I'm going to
encounter the divine or have I just sort
of accepted that that's not a thing in
my world even if I'm a believer in it
right I might be I might agree that it's
there but not really kind of be desiring
it and wanting it or expecting it
certainly and I think that's one of the
things that Orthodox Christianity and
some sense takes as a given actually you
know that that simply God is there and
he actually does love us and he's
touching us and and and connecting with
us and and his Saints are just they're
kind of on the edge of our of our
consciousness yeah right so but I think
that's something that right now it's
it's such a great time to talk about
this because there's a sense I'm seeing
in even in the secular community I'm
seeing an awakening to as as science
reaches its limit you could say in terms
of understanding the human person and is
his facing is hitting up against the
problem of consciousness and the problem
of what it means for a meaning making
conscious agent to be the one who is
observing the world and how that
interaction is extremely complicated
the possibility of speaking of what what
other the other only word I can use for
people to understand is of speaking of
these principalities of the notion that
there are principalities which surround
us and and which are forming our world
and we are we have the chance to
participate in that and
and this kind of amazing hierarchy of
saints and of angels leads up and points
us to the absolute transcendence I think
that I think that now is just such a
great time to talk about that I have
seen in my dealing with kind of post
atheist people at first when you talk
about angels they think you're talking
about you know I mean they think you're
just talking that they're actually
winged people that fly around in the sky
and to finally saying oh okay alright I
see that I see what you mean and I also
see what you mean when you point to the
fact that even you as a person there's
an aspect of you that you cannot fully
contain within the quantitative world
you could say and it's kind of leading
people to the - - now again really
looking at old stories looking at myths
and the great thing about tokine is he
was able to create a world that was
almost was so completely coherent in
terms of its mythology in terms of its
mythology is not at all Christian and I
think that's also important it's not at
all Christian in its let's say it is
outer aspect yeah right you look at it
you see that the pattern that is behind
it
reveal something that can help you
understand what it means to be a
Christian in the world and I think that
that to me is one of the most
interesting things that Tokyo can can
bring to us yeah and and I mean it's
interesting if you read like Yuri
Tolkien's letters for instance he talks
a lot about about his intentions for his
creation and well sub creation to use
the Tolkien turn right and you know one
of the things that he says is that he
says that it's actually a Christian and
Catholic work particularly but there's a
lot of people who are not Christians or
maybe have no religious involvement at
all who if they read that that bit from
his letter might think wait what you
know I don't see Jesus in here anywhere
what do you mean by that you know but I
think part of the difficulty of course
is that we often look at things on a
more superficial level yeah rather than
seeing kind of the deeper substrates of
what's going on yeah and you know it's
it's almost like the I kind of see it
the way that it's almost a token world
is an alternative
new told Testament you know where there
you have all these these types these
small types of characters that will
manifest one aspect let's say of Christ
or one aspect of the the fullness of the
Christian revelation just like in the
Old Testament all the figures kind of
point to Christ but Christ is not there
you know and so it's it is like kind of
this funnel that that points you to to
to to to the final revelation you could
say which is not in them this story and
I think that all good stories that's
what they should do I always kind of I
always you know a lot of people really
like CS Lewis I remember reading CS
Lewis when I was younger and he liking a
few of the books but not totally getting
into it so much and I think part of it
was because of that problem is that you
know a salon is Jesus okay I get it
and and and so but then and then it gets
weird because sometimes he does things
and you're wondering okay well if a
salon is Jesus why is he doing this and
why is he acting like this there's some
it just becomes very very strange
whereas in token you don't you don't
have that problem because all the
characters are kind of manifesting
different aspects of reality and and if
you kind of bring it together then you
see something behind it you know yeah
yeah and I mean I have loved Lewis
probably just almost as long as I've
loved token but the point that you make
I think is a good one and you know I
would say that Tolkien's middle-earth
and well actually middle-earth is just a
continent in his world but his his sub
creation the whole cosmos was created is
much more perfect and coherent than
Lewis's Narnia yeah but I if I can just
give one small plug for Lewis I think
you actually and this is not for Narnia
I think Lewis actually achieved this the
thing that talking I think did best I
think he achieved that Lewis achieved it
in some measure with his final novel
which is till we have faces okay which
is not you know within Narnia and it's
really a pagan story actually and I
think because Lewis wasn't trying to
present Jesus in particular that it
actually presents a more Christian
world then then the Narnia does
interestingly enough but I've not read
it so maybe you know this is a plug for
me to go into that yeah you should check
it out I think it is actually Louis's
best work and although not as well known
by any means if anything else really
that he wrote I think just about but way
of course we're here to talk talking
though so all right so let's talk let's
talk about Toki
so maybe you can tell us a little bit
about the the premise of this new
podcast I think it's called aman thul
I'm probably not pronouncing that right
as well you got it you got it
all right and I will put for everybody I
will definitely put a link to that in
the description of the video but maybe
you can tell us a bit about the premise
of the podcast and where you're going
cuz I I think you're still at the you
have what two episodes maybe three now
and so so it's at the beginning yeah the
third episode is I'm not sure when this
will air but at the third episode is
slated to air on March 25th so okay so
I'll probably put this up before okay
great
so yeah so you know we're well underway
now you know got a few under our belts
and the whole point of almond Sewell is
well first actually I should say that
where does it now fit kind of in the the
constellation of Tolkien podcasts
because there are dozens of that right
and when I when I first conceiving this
idea I was like man I mean how do I even
get heard kind of in the midst of all of
these other things you know I I you know
I have my own audience I figure well
these the people that will kind of start
I'll start with you but but there's lots
of them and one thing that I did notice
is that most Tolkien podcasts their deal
is essentially let's take this book or
maybe this series of books and we're
gonna read through it chapter by chapter
and offer commentary along the way right
almost all of them do that and some of
them do it really well some of them not
so well that's right I won't name any
names but I thought okay well I can't do
that because that then you know at least
puts me doing the same thing that
they're doing and people would say well
why should I just listen to yet another
chapter by chapter commentary right
which I mean I think it's a cool
approach but but so I'm not doing that
instead this is a much more topical
approach and it's based on
conversation rather than commentary
although sometimes that commentary has
given his conversation and what we're
doing is we're taking themes from
Tolkien's works which include not just
his epic fantasy but also even has his
letters and some of his non fantasy
works we're gonna get to and looking at
what he did and and asking the question
that he himself suggests should be asked
from his work so we talked a little bit
about allegory just a couple minutes ago
when we were talking about CS Lewis and
you know Aslan equals Jesus that kind of
thing so Tolkien doesn't like allegory
and he's very explicit about that in one
of his practices to the Lord of the
Rings yeah but instead he favors what he
calls applicability yeah so if if I had
to pick one word for what it is we're
trying to do with the amon Sewell
podcast it's this question of
applicability right and as a Christian
and as a specifically Orthodox Christian
then that's the kind of applicability
that I want to talk about and so just to
give some examples of where we've
already gone so first is the very first
episode which I did with my friend
Stephen Christopher Oh
we talked specifically about this
question of accessing the transcendent
in an imminent eyes experience of the
world which is what most of us are
having most the time right how does how
did Tolkien's works help us to navigate
that and like one of the things that we
talked about in the midst of that first
episode was the fact that that journey
is actually being taken by the hobbits
in the Lord of the Rings you know they
live in this town where everything is
agrarian and domesticated and pastoral
and and life is about creature comforts
family and friends and you know all that
good stuff right but the idea that
there's dragons that there's wizards
that there's anything outside of you
know the four farthings there's a bigger
story happening here right they're just
not even aware of that and when it you
know it might exist in kind of old tales
you know and then and then one guy who
goes off to kind of experience that
comes back and everyone regards them
it's kind of crazy right so it's kind of
Plato's cave you know oh oh we're good
and and you know the hobbits leave the
saw
and they're being they're being coached
along the way by people like Aragorn and
Gandalf actually how to navigate this
much larger story including transcendent
elements yeah right so for instance you
know hobbits will just talk about
anything anywhere as an example and
sometimes Gandalf for Aragorn
particularly say don't talk about that
here or you know let's wait until
morning or that kind of thing suggesting
that there is power in language that
they're not aware of right so that was
one thing that we we did and then in my
second big episode which is actually
episode three which I did with Deaconess
Nicholas Kotar yeah we had him on that
on our channel and he did we did a
discussion with it so people will watch
yeah yeah you know we talked
specifically about storytelling so some
of the same stuff you talked with them
about you know at a much greater length
and you know and and what what does what
impact does reading stories and of
storytelling have on us as as human
persons and how does that connect us
with prayer and how does that connect us
with scenes so so it is this question of
applicability and I mean you might you
might describe it as pastoral theology
and maybe but I wouldn't I wouldn't
narrow it to just that you know but but
that's kind of what we're trying to do
and you know some of the episodes are
going to be more sort of higher level
analyses with a lot of theology and then
others are going to be not so
theologically nerdy I guess what is the
Olli do you come nerdy out of that
anyway just but you know I mean my my
deal is that I'm kind of a popularizer
anyway you'll never get academic you
know that's kind of not what we're doing
so so yeah that's that's what almond
school is about and the reason why we
chose the title in particular is that
aman thul is a place in the Tolkien
legendarium where it's also called
Weathertop almond soul is its enduring
name which means hill of winds and it's
a place where a number of events happen
in the legendarium but especially for
those who are familiar with Lord
it's where the hobbits along with
Aragorn have that battle with the nazgûl
and the the witch-king of Angmar stabs
Frodo
in the shoulder with the Morgul blade so
it's a really important place not just
because of that event but for lots of
other reasons if you want to hear about
all of that listen episode 2 so I'm just
sort of plugging as I go right that's
all good but yeah so that's what it's
about and there's all these questions of
memory and of seeing you know from a far
distance and seeing things that are not
normally visible to the eye although
these are themes that have to do with
Weathertop actually okay all right so I
like all of that and I and I wanted to
kind of make that a lot of the recurring
motif in the podcast yeah I wanna I
really want to get back to this idea to
me the the issue that you talk about in
that token said he doesn't like allegory
I've always really felt sympathy for
what he was saying and I've always felt
like people didn't understand what he
meant and I'm not sure I totally
understand what he meant but I have my
own idea for the reason that I don't
like allegory which is that let's say
what I would call true symbol like fake
symbolism is the kind of nut fake or
lower symbolism or lower imagistic
speaking is the kind that we talked
about where it's like this figure
represents this other figure so you know
I'm gonna have I'm gonna write a story
and then they'll be a veiled figure
that's gonna be availed allusion to
Donald Trump let's say and so here
here's this character who represents
Donald Trump and that to me is is a kind
of very weak version of imagistic
speaking and you could call that
allegory or metaphor or something like
that
and to me true symbolism is something
which is structural that is there's an
underlying structure which is actually
the structure of reality it's like
you've actually intuited the structure
of how the world lays itself out in
terms of of what a story is turn of how
we experience the world and in terms of
how we we are living in the world and
then you you you create this this story
that follows that pattern and so then
like you said
like the word applicability because then
you can say you can kind of see through
the story the pattern and then you can
apply it to anything right you can apply
to any aspect of your life because it
has a universal has a universal aspect
to it or a universal structure you could
say or something of that I always call
it like it's actually how you experience
the world it's like some some people are
able to intuit it and so they they are
able to lay it out in a fictional story
but it's not it's fictional but it's not
like you said it's not just this
character represents war this this
character represents that you know
Hitler in World War two are the that
this aspect represents a nuclear bomb
something like that like to me that is a
week a week you yeah and and I think
that when when a story becomes
allegorical and I think I think you're
on the right track in terms of my
understanding of what Tolkien is
criticizing allegory you know what
happens then is your ability to process
it becomes reduced because it's only
supposed to be about this one thing yeah
and and so ok I got there I learned my
lesson now what you know you know
meanwhile like for instance I've already
gotten lots of email for this podcast
which has really been amazing to me and
one of the emails that I got we actually
featured on one of the episodes at least
a portion of it there's this man who
talks about how when he was young he had
a very difficult life and actually was
contemplating suicide on a number of
occasions and that the thing that pulled
him away from that is a scene from the
two towers where Aragorn is standing up
on the battlements of Helm's Deep you
know in the face of just incredible odds
I mean they're going to be defeated as
far as you know by that point in the
story and and he stands there in the
face of all these massive horrifying
monsters and tells them to be gone no
get out because you don't know what
tomorrow is gonna bring you don't know
what is gonna happen in the new day and
and this man told told um told me in
this email that that seemed inspired him
to to sort of face down his own demons
even
a kid and and tell him to get out you
know because he didn't know what
tomorrow is gonna bring and you know
that is one kind of applicability where
you can identify yourself now he can't
look at Aragorn and say I'm like Aragorn
you know because he's just a kid but he
could but you might maybe but but
Aragorn doesn't stand for him like great
exactly we have to be really kind of you
know deluded to think that but if you
were told that Aragorn stands for Jesus
hmm and that's all Aragorn kind of is is
just this now I would say he is a kind
of Christ figure but if that he stands
he's a stand-in for Jesus then it's
harder to kind of say well I can be like
that and and you know face down the
demons because you could say well he's
God so of course he can make that kind
of comment you know of course he can say
yet tomorrow I'm just gonna blast it you
know yeah you know so I and I and I
think that also this realm of
applicability opens up all kinds of
possibilities for conversation mm-hmm
right you know it's not this sort of
contained discourse where if you say
well I want to connect it like for
instance when I talk with Deacon
Nicholas Kotar we talked about high
geography and and he even talked about
hi-yah he's that were sort of invented
for Saints about whom there was almost
no historical data yeah right well you
know if it's just allegory that's what
Lord of the Week rings is and you kind
of have no right sort of import that
yeah you know and and connected but
applicability absolutely you know I
think that's really and the thing is
like for example that scene that you
mentioned in terms of Aragorn standing
on the wall looking at the hordes
there's a there is in that scene a what
I would call a structural element which
is right like it's it's it's the right
image for that experience that this
person was having in terms of being
faced with you know these demons in his
life and via feeling overwhelmed and so
and and it it's I often because it's so
obvious for us when we see it because
it's so intuitive we see that scene and
we it's so intuitive that we can't
really explain it's like this of course
this is what it should be but you can
imagine another scene
for example where it's it's someone
sitting at a table eating a feast and
then that's a different scene like he
couldn't say to the demons be gone
because he's sitting inside the castle
at a table eating food and so the the
fact of standing on a wall already is
something that we can analogically
experience in in our life this idea of
being on the limit of something we can
experience in terms of meaning not just
in terms of physical reality but the
analogy is actually real of being on the
edge we use it that experience that
expression all the time to talk about
someone who is strained who is faced by
all these difficulties like he's
standing on the edge and so standing on
the edge and then having the courage to
look straight on at these demons not
hide not not just pretend they're not
there but to look at them and to say
okay I'm not gonna pretend but I'm gonna
tell you I'm going to you know I'm going
to say go you be gone because I I trust
the few like I trust I trust I mean
obvious I was I trust God but I have
trust that things can change I have
trusted that this situation is not
eternal this situation is not the one
that is going to going to pervade and so
the that that's where you see this uh
like you said it's applicability coming
from something which is so right
intuitively you know it hits you right
there in a way that is almost impossible
to explain for so many people you know
they have that so many people that I
know had that experience for example
watching Braveheart where they they even
my wife she said like she said
Braveheart is basically one of the
reasons why she kind of came back to
Christianity you know who she kept she
kind of really rededicated her her life
and it never stopped since then because
of that that because of an imagistic
taking you through the story of someone
who's faced with insane opposition but
won't back down and and you know will go
until the end it shows you that how
stories and how participating in a story
is really a kind of therapy you could
say it's it's it's a kind of reprogram
it can be a reprogramming of of your
life it can be a reprogramming of
reality and so that's why I tell people
that
Surgical experience or the liturgical
year and the surgical calendar is the
ultimate version of that where I follow
the story of Christ through the year and
we especially during this time now
during Lent and then during Holy weekend
and at paska it's like we are diving
into this story we're going through
words
we're lamenting with Christ's death
we're doing all that because we know
that part engaging in stories and
participating in them actually
transforms reality transforms the world
yeah yeah and and if we try to present
like for instance if I were to you know
had talked to this man when he was a kid
and said to him now look you know sure
you're being you're being bullied and
you know you're valuable you should
don't kill yourself you know like that
Falls much flatter yeah then seeing this
image of you know this man who's
destined to be king but maybe he's not
gonna make it you know by that point the
story you kind of don't know that that's
actually gonna happen you know and and
there's something about images there's
something about story that actually in a
sense is much more convincing in terms
of altering the way that I function then
you know actually reorients my desires
in a way that is far more powerful than
simply offering an argument and you know
the irony of course is that here in the
early 21st century we still kind of at
least tend to speak as though you know
these Enlightenment ideas of well if I
make a rational argument then I'll
convince you and having convinced you
now that will change the way that you
live you know that will change your
behavior that you know and and the you
know this is ironic because that's not
the way the human beings actually tends
to function right exactly
there's a difference between saying okay
I agree with you because you're making
an argument that I that I can't overcome
and actually becoming a different person
or B exactly you know and and can be
even worse when you've received the
argument and you know that you should
change something but it's like it's not
happening
can make it worse yeah like it can leak
in fact to despair and step that's right
you know like like I I know I mean and
and you know the Apostle Paul wrestles
with this I I know the good but I don't
do it you know and I I do the evil that
I don't want to do and you know and so
that's an indication of an orientation
of desire and orienting desire is a
different a different ballgame really
than than just setting out arguments and
convincing people and I mean you know
it's funny even just kind of in our our
political arena we have lots of
arguments that go back and forth and yet
no one seems to be convinced yeah no
matter how good and how well refined you
know the arguments are made and and
that's one of the reasons that I love
Tolkien's works is that he he offers an
image of how to be an image of how to
think how to desire how to live that is
actually much more kind of immediately
accessible and not not imposing itself
on the person yeah it really is kind of
an invitation yeah you know so like you
know at the end of the hobbit where or
near the end of the hobbit where Thorin
says to Bilbo essentially you know if
people were more like you you know
really valuing you know good food and
good cheer over hoarded gold then the
world would be a better place right
it'll be a happier place and that's a
much more powerful moment having lived
the story up to that point then someone
simply saying now look it's not good to
be greedy right just sort of like moral
precepts you know yeah
there's room for those like there's room
for those I mean we have them we also
have in the Bible but like you said once
it enters into the story realm and once
you have examples and you have people
that you can look up to that whether
it's in fictional stories or or it's
Saints that have lived that way and then
you can kind of engage with those
stories then the transformational
the transformational aspect is is far
greater yeah I think that's inevitable
and I think and even the Bible is much
more narrative than it is kind of of
course yeah and that's what that's one
of the things that I always try to help
because people really struggle modern
people really struggle to understand
liturgy and understand the liturgical
way of seeing the world and the
liturgical experience and and that's in
the liturgical year all those things
it's so hard for people to to understand
why we why would waste our time you know
celebrating Pentecost and ascension and
and you know why do we have these long
services that kind of take you through
and I mean it's it's difficult for
people to fully grasp especially when
they see a liturgy for the first time
but once you start to to understand the
pattern within the the liturgy you see
that it is also a it has a story form
it's taking us into the mystery and
there's different cycles where it's like
moving you closer and closer to the
mystery you know and and and then
closing off the doors and then bringing
us in and then uniting us with the
angels and so there's this whole really
this whole I mean it's almost more like
a poem in that sense it's almost like a
like a song or like a poem which is also
which also has a pattern form which is
kind of bringing you towards this this
crescendo you could say moment and that
it's those types of structures those
types of experiences which although
sometimes might not be as
transformational on an immediately
emotional experience you know that you
know you don't necessarily leave the
church crying and regretting you know
your sins all the time but usually that
extra that emotional experience of like
you know you've been convicted and you
go home crying that usually lasts you
know a few days and then and then in a
time yeah whereas the the deep
transformation of the pattern of your
being is a it's a it's kind of this slow
ascension that we all participate in and
and that's something that I've found is
in the liturgical world like the
liturgical Christian Christianity is
something that is is it's difficult to
get people to understand but it's very
very profound transformation yeah and
one of the reasons why I personally
experienced Tolkien as a kind of
preparation for liturgical life is
because the way that liturgy tells
stories is actually a more traditional
way of telling stories then we tend to
expect now and I'll give an example of
that you know so one of the one of the
Tolkien podcasts that I listen to
there the part that I'm listening to
right now they're going through The
Silmarillion okay so which is sort of
tokens Old Testament kind of which I've
not read by the way this summer and I
get discouraged looking at it no no my
nine-year-old son is tearing through it
okay so so don't worry all right
I know I was kind of stalked like he was
like that he told my wife that I wasn't
reading it to my kids fast enough and so
he when they were at the library
together he went and looked up where
they had the copies of Sumerian and
Gotha librarian to show him where he so
he could check his own copy out and not
be bound to the one that's locked in my
office and so he's just reading it
himself anyway so so in this podcast are
going through The Silmarillion and often
one of the things that they'll say is oh
you know here's of another place where
Tolkien gives a spoiler mm-hmm right so
you know often in the stories it'll tell
you often in the title of the particular
tale it'll tell you the end right but
like for instance you know of the fall
of Gondolin hmm spoiler alert the city
is destroyed you just look through the
table of contents you kind of know what
happens and now you don't get this as
much in the Lord of the Rings there's
not as many kind of spoilers in that
sense but the the way that that tokens
tell stories particularly miss
Silmarillion is much more helical and in
that there's a sense of there's always a
kind of looking forward that's happening
and you you know you're and and there's
almost an expectation that even the
first time you're experiencing this
story is already some in some sense a
repeat right again right so liturgical
life is that way you know by the time my
kids for instance
become really cognizant of the fact that
at Christmas that the that their this is
really telling a story a specific story
they will have already heard the story
many many times but you know another
thing that happens and this does happen
in Lord of the Rings is there are
moments which are completely sort of
unrealistic mm-hmm and by that I just
mean something sort of miraculous
happens but like for instance after the
death of Boromir okay I think which
happens the end of the Fellowship of the
Ring and you get I'm sorry I think
actually happens beginning to tears you
know the books and the movies are
starting to sort of they meld in your
mind no and I'm I know I'm already
regretting this because I'm getting
email from people saying that's not what
happens in the book but anyway whichever
wherever it happens in the books it does
happen that Boromir dies and now this is
something that doesn't happen in movies
which is that you got Aragorn and
Legolas and Gimli and they they put him
on one of the boats to essentially give
him a burial not at sea but in a river
in the water and you know they put the
swords of his ending the weapons of his
enemies down at a speed and have his you
know his his hands clasp together on his
breast and and then they set him off and
they they sing to him he sing this dirge
this funeral dirge that is written for
Boromir right and it's like wait how can
that happen there you know how did they
compose them that they're improvising oh
yeah like let's look this out right now
before we see from the books there's no
way that within stir the action of the
book that can be and so it's a more
mythological way of telling it it's kind
of breaking its way into this more novel
style of story which is brings it right
and and that's so liturgical right right
it's there you know for instance when in
in in Holy Week when there's kind of
even moments of sort of reenactment it's
not just now let's just tell the story
and then we'll have a kind of a
commentary later commentary is happening
the whole time right there's all kinds
of like let's pause here at this and
sing a whole song about it
you know which kind of doesn't make
sense in terms of the sort of
action-movie way of telling story yeah
yeah we're more used to now but it makes
total sense in a more mythological way
of telling story yeah it's a communal
experience that's repeated over and over
and so then the the funeral dirge of
Boromir becomes part of the story not
because that's what happens in the
moment like it couldn't have happened
right it just doesn't humanly make any
sense yeah you know I totally agree that
some of my favorite moments during
during Holy Week are those those moments
where there's that you know at the
crucifixion of Christ there's a deep
mourning of Christ's death but then it's
it's almost it's there's still two
telling us well he's gonna he's coming
back and they're calling Ike were
calling like resurrect resurrect like
we're calling the Christ to resurrect
and so it's it's it's it is it's a very
different way of telling a story and and
it is like this cyclical kind of we know
what's going to happen we're still
participating it participating in it and
it's transforming us but what would we
know the Telos of this thing you know
and so it's yeah it's a III I totally
agree that's a very very different way
of telling stories and it's something
that that we you know this idea of the
shock ending or this idea like you said
of this spoiler it's something that hope
ancient people didn't care at all about
because now participatory storytelling
and so you just enter into the story and
you kind of enact it even when they
would tell the stories of you know that
when people would tell the stories of
the Iliad or the they would tell poems
of ancient Greece or whatever you know
there was this this everybody knew was
gonna happen but it was they would they
still are going to hear it every year or
you know several times a year this
you're gonna enter into it and know that
it's their story in that they're they're
engaging in it yeah and and within that
context then novelty which still has a
place yeah comes about delighting and
about finding a new angle to to see the
story so for instance within the church
year there's new hymns that are written
right you know that and have to do with
the exact same events that we
has been talking about right and and you
know why is it that with you know this
massive corpus of stuff that's been
published after Tolkien's debt why is it
that people want to read like five
different versions of Beren and lúthien
we did because it kind of doesn't matter
that even their they don't even work
with each other and I mean they it's
still kind of one story but like for
instance Beren and lúthien in The
Silmarillion Baron is a human he's a man
but in the sort of novel version so to
speak that just came out within the past
couple years
Baron is actually in a health mmm-hmm
which radically changes the whole story
of Beren and lúthien because kind of the
whole deal or so we thought was that
lúthien and immortal elf joins himself
to Baron a mortal man and so she then
she accepts death right well that's not
how it works out in the person you know
it's not it's not the same story exactly
and yet the fact that we kind of
approach you from different angles and
even some of the details don't match up
yeah that's okay within a mythological
way of telling stories and if you think
about just the four Gospels yeah of
course there's not a perfect
harmonization that can happen with all
of the details on the four Gospels and
you know what that's okay yeah that's
okay and it wasn't I would say it wasn't
even expected in the first century that
that was the way you would tell like
let's make this into the kind of thing
that is perfectly consistent you know
for a court of law you know so so yeah
yeah there's there's like I said I I
it's funny because I mean I've been
Orthodox for over 20 years now but I've
been I've been the whole time kind of
gradually working out how it is that my
experience of tokens works prepare me
for a liturgical life and continues to
deepen it right it continues to deepen
it over and over and over again you know
like I'm a priest so my job is to stand
it an altar and offer up to sacra
sacrifice of bread and wine that is sort
of the key core thing that I do with
myself and you know the idea that I
would stand there on the threshold of
the transcendent and make this
connection not on behalf of people like
they're not there and I'm doing it
instead of them I'm not a proxy but
rather that I'm at the head of
them and seeing now come follow me you
know in in some sense you know isn't
isn't that kind of sacrificial action of
very much a sort of a Gandalf way of
being you know candles job is not to
solve everybody's problems yeah you know
Gandalf jobs is to point them towards
ultimately the will of the one God you
know which in tokens world is called
aloo Matar yeah although he doesn't does
that by bringing them along on the story
like taking them into the story exactly
and of course centers even within the
story itself you get moments where
people reflect on the fact that they're
in a story yeah I know it's not sort of
the pulling back you know removal the so
called fourth wall like an eater
but there is a sense of like we're part
of a great tale you know and and and and
and that again sheds another kind of
light on what it is that's happening you
know so yeah it's it's I don't know it
it's endlessly delightful and I think
that delight actually calls forth from
us the deepest part of who we really are
mmm-hmm there's something about delight
that does that
alright I think that I think that you
you basically you've basically wrapped
up our discussion this is a great time
to finish it because it's on a nice high
point so uh father and I I really
appreciate you coming here and and
discussing this with me and I would want
to call everybody to check out Allen
Sewell podcast you will and father
Andrews other writings and his other
podcast for all of you that all of you
that are interested in stories and are
looking at Christianity trying to figure
out you know you know how what it means
to get into that story what it means to
live inside the Christian story I would
say that here are some interesting hints
for you to to discover that so so father
and I hope we can do this again yes once
the podcast is is going for a little
while we'll bring you back and and hear
some more some more stories of how it's
it's affecting people and and and you
have to come and be a guest on it
sure yeah I not I am NOT a toking expert
good so yeah sure send me a message and
I will be there so everybody thank
thanks again for your attention I hope
you enjoyed our conversation and I'll
see you soon she enjoyed this discussion
and the content we're putting out on
symbolism get involved I love to read
all your comments in the comment section
you can also share this on social media
we have a Facebook group where people
engage in discussion as well please
subscribe if you're not subscribe and
also consider supporting us financially
if you can you can go to my website
www.marykay.co.uk/awilliam visit